je souhaite que les trois candidats
suscita vrai débat un partant de nos
ateliers de la ''refondation'' partant
aussi de ce qu'ils ressentent voit bien
chez laurent wauquiez que le sentiment
d'appartenance à une communauté
nationale c'est quelque chose de fort et
uni dans la clarté
monsieur bilan n'appartient pas pour moi
aux valeurs qui sont les miennes alors
que beyoncé crazy dans le sens commun
c'est c'est bien ça recommence et
l'émanation des manifs pour tous au sein
des républicains certains chez les
républicains demandent à ce que monsieur
biya en soient exclues ou ce que la
convention qui me sens commun aux
républicains soient dénoncés vous quelle
est votre position par rapport à cette
question moi il s'est séparé totalement
la famille politique je parle pas de
chance coma qui n'est pas globalement ma
tasse de thé
je suis un homme trop engagé dans la
laïcité même si j'ai des convictions
est-ce que sans ce contrat personnel que
tout le monde connaît mais sur ce commun
c'est autre chose que son président je
n'ai pas entendu de la part de sens
commun en tant que tel on peu avant
l'heure où bien loin se lance donc en
ont en commun on n'en aurait pas avoir
un double appartenance
dès qu'on a franchi cette barrière qui
nous rapprocherait de l'ex-femme avec
l'idée d'envisager un dialogue avec le
dialogue
marion maréchal-le pen c'est quoi ça